one come to invite people from outside
the first image they get war bloodshed
kidnapping suicide bombing all this
violence we get through the media and
the reality is not like that the
beautiful tigress is breathtaking they
remind you the Garden of Eden my name is
Nabil Moussa and I am a warrior keeper
Waterkeeper is the voice for rivers our
mission is keeping our waterways
swimmable
fishable drinkable I am the first water
keeper in the Middle East I spent most
of my childhood ride by the river
catching fish playing with frogs and
that chasing dragonfly I have some
beautiful memories and I want to bring
them back the problems in an appetite
was River dams urban waste gravel mine
oil refinery and oil wells garbage from
picnickers my current mission is
educating people average raising
awareness and water quality monitoring
when the water gets blue tea find out
how did that happen was the polluter I
mean a lot of people what I'm paddling
some people they are positive some
people they are negative they tell me
you are trying to you know stop all this
pollution we've been having them for for
years and years but our rivers are our
lifeblood and if we don't protect them
our life is not going to be safe I want
to raise awareness and tell next
generation action need to be taken I
wanted people to go to nature more
appreciate the water more and to protect
it
I have a right to inspect this water is
my water everybody would so I am hopeful
I am hopeful about a feature of Iraq and
Kurdistan yes we won't get growing up in
Montana I feel like I had kind of a
special opportunity to be outside a lot
that's kind of where a love of wildlife
you started for me that dies out and a
lot of kids and for me it continues all
right guys we're Dan well guy has been
named yet my name is Wesley Larson I'm a
master student working in wildlife
conservation and then uh some circles
I'm known as brisket when I first
started deciding that I should get into
a wildlife field I found dr. Tom Smith
at BYU I started by working with polar
bears on Alaska's North Slope and then
that kind of transition in the black
bear works down here in Utah in Bryce
Canyon Bryce Canyon like other national
parks who do have bears they've had a
kind of a history with was visitor
conflict and was bears that maybe are
getting into campsites so what we're
doing is we're tracking the Bears to
learn what habitats they're using just
to see what the park can do better to
make it easier for visitors to avoid
there's what we're doing is we're
fitting black bears with GPS collars and
then I'll go into the den with the bear
to inject it with some drugs the bear
that called the fleet I can pull it out
and you know just give it a full checkup
it's probably the most scary thing we do
just because there's way got sometimes
they're really unhappy - yeah hey hey
hey
[Music]
Hey okay Jenna I have had to crawl up
trees after bears it's an interesting
job for sure people do have this
knee-jerk reaction to see an animal that
the data it or an animal that's wearing
a collar and think that you know might
be being hurt and the thing that they
don't realize is that we really care
about these animals probably more than
just about anyone getting out into the
wilderness and having these kind of
experiences helps you understand that we
depend on wildlife and wildlife depends
on us and that's really what
conservation is all about giving the
space and the respect to these animals
that they deserve and really learning as
much about them as we can
[Music]
this program is about the only way of
collecting these right in a very
scientific and methodological way you
spend so much time preparing once you
get down there you don't know whether
you can do this or not and then the
first time you find a meteorite you say
yes I can do this
[Music]
my name is Constantine sang I'm at
Southwest Research Institute in Boulder
Colorado and the plan G scientists
studying plan G atmosphere we said total
of two months on the ice and we
collected approximately 569 meteorites
the scientific expeditions called and
Matt show for Antarctic session meet
right it's masa funded and what we try
to understand is how formational saw
system began and how the plans evolved
the way they look today three
tranquility the beauty the awesomeness
there's no hyperbole that's too great
for Antarctica the ice is crystal blue
the snow is thick and the Sun is
brilliant
when we're on the ice field we live very
basic we live in tents with power
supplied by solar panels and dripping
ice water the reason why we go down
justice is because these are black rocks
from a white surface that are much
easier to find as they go through the
atmosphere they start to burn up and
they couldn't black fusion crust and
that's very distinct from any
terrestrial rock by studying meteorites
we're actually looking at this
primordial history oh that's awesome
this is a direct piece of evidence how
the planets evolved and formed and how
did life evolved on the earth no one
gets to go out there except for
scientists and very rich folks so
there's a huge privilege to go out and
experience something that is
life-changing
[Music]
[Applause]
when you enter with the note there it's
really like going into another world
like leaving the leaving the planet
behind this is speeding up really
exploring something new and I feel very
lucky to be able to see them
[Music]
my name is Julian bold I've been free
diving and scuba diving for the last 15
years in many different locations always
trying to find the best diving spots
those illnesses are our caves all the
Senators are connected to each other and
the water goes and flows come one
candidate to another San Jose to end up
in the sea the first time you you go
into Selassie it's something you don't
see anywhere else it's completely
different experience than diving in the
ocean at the beginning it can be a
little bit scary but really quickly the
beauty of the place would just take over
[Music]
some senses are very welcoming sometimes
so big and so clear that the really
gives you the sensation you go into a
church and you don't want to talk too
loud and not disturb anyone
and so other senators I always to have a
little bit like an atmosphere more like
hell with the dead trees and boron and
so for the mayans we're using the
cenotes for a very long time basically
the land where we are at the state where
the leading people live and then
underneath the penalty's into the ground
was the place for the dead every should
not say I have a different personality
but I also thing that he really affects
your own personality
at some point you kind of enter into
like a meditation stage for me on this
devices
[Music]